we're going to make fun of Joe Biden
because we have this story from the New
York Post it's big news breaking news
from 11 57 a.m Biden stumbles up Air
Force One stairs again leaving Poland
you know that's karma that's a that's a
someone uh carpet I think Carpe dongta
made a meme where Trump throws his hat
and he's Palestinian and then a
boomerangs around and hits bite and he
falls up the stairs this is what we get
ladies and gentlemen your president not
only abandoning the American people
visiting foreign countries and then
falling up the stairs that's that's your
president to be fair that's a lot of
stairs for a dude that's almost 80. yeah
what are they going to build an
escalator an escalator what I want to
know is where is SNL on this I mean when
when when Gerald Ford fell down the
stairs uh in the 70s when he was
president that's what made Chevy Chase
famous was making fun of Gerald Ford
when he fell down the stairs and it's
like this has happened twice now and you
see nothing from places like SNL or or
any of the comedians making fun of it it
doesn't make any sense to me
baby The Babylon bees tearing it up they
have uh they're one of their new
articles Biden promises to get rid of
these Resort fees wait I'm sorry Biden
promises to get rid of those Resort fees
by the time World War III starts have
you seen him tweeting about getting rid
of Resort fees over the last last three
weeks these ninety dollar secret fees
are ruining America under my watch will
make sure and it's like are these really
your priorities dude you just he's
tweeted about it like three times in the
last two weeks he has mentioned a couple
of things that are very silly like very
frivolous and this isn't comedy this is
true yeah Resort fees suck I get it but
but juxtaposed with the Ukrainian stuff
in East Palestine it's like what is he
the Babylon bee wrote this headline
Biden promises to get rid of those
Resort fees by the time world war three
starts but that's literally what he's
saying it's like he so he didn't
literally say I will get rid of these
fees before the start of World War Three
but world war three is on the we're on
the cusp of a major conflict he's like
don't worry we're gonna get those Resort
fees down it's like what completely
people's whole city is blanketed in this
chemical that killed their livestock and
is like floating in their water and then
you're like Mr President will you help
the poor people of East Palestine I will
by cutting those Resort fees so when
they're evacuating their Hometown it'll
be a little cheaper out of their pocket
maybe they're not making fun of him
falling up the steps because he's old
and it's like elder abuse racism yeah
whereas like Gerald Ford was still how
old was Ford was he like in his early
60s or something no he was able to I
mean I think he's in his 50s or
something so he was younger anything
he's more of just a guy falling down
right but again it is I guess a little
funny but when you do it twice man I
mean when you do the same thing twice
yeah SNL should be all over the that and
and I think Tim is right you know it is
a cult and it just says we cannot make
fun of the Holy One we cannot make fun
of the person that's carrying our water
for us and and it's really sad it's
really sad this is what uh the president
is tweeting about right now hidden junk
fees are taking money out of the pockets
of average Americans thanks to our
efforts most of the country's largest
banks are getting rid of fees for
bounced checks we're going to lower
overdraft fees next well that's that's
really great uh I mean cool do you have
anything to add about the people whose
entire city is blanketed in toxic
chemicals and whose livestock are dying
I would be interested to hear what you
had to say about that one I'm curious oh
I'm sorry before that he says our
support for Ukraine will not waver NATO
will not be divided we will not Tire oh
NATO yeah he's not talking about us he's
in what is his Bucharest Bucharest nine
leaders have provided critical security
assistance do you say anything NATO NATO
NATO NATO
uh earlier I was briefed on a winter
storm okay is he just not saying
anything Ukrainian refugees democracies
around the world uh-huh Christians in
Ash Wednesday okay well that one's okay
you know all right I can respect that
one he's talking about Americans at
least yo it's it's like
in it to him none of this even happened
did he even mention it once I maybe it
has to have had mentioned it I thought
he tweeted about it once but while he
was on his way to Ukraine right wow I
mean that that that's an air in the face
you know you got a toxic chemical spill
it's a problem well I'll be over in
Ukraine given 500 million dollars from
your from your taxes to a country you
can't point a toy on a map I think it
was Anna De armas somebody there was an
actor saying that the age of social
media has basically killed the uh the
the movie star it's basically there are
no more movie stars now it's it's a lot
I think a lot less about the art that
you make and more about who you are as a
person because it's a lot more prevalent
and obvious now and it's the same thing
with the president they don't hide
behind this Visage of like the title now
you get to see this guy in his daily
behavior and it's insane look look look
sorry man just look at this picture
this is worse this is like 1970s crap
this this this tweet from Joe Biden is
worse than nothing he said after my
speech did I spoke with EPA Michael
Reagan shared Brown Bill Johnson Shapiro
dewine about our ongoing efforts in East
Palestine Ohio a reaffirmed my
commitment to making sure they have
everything they need let me give you the
latest and there is a picture of him
sitting on the phone and I don't know
where he is but it's just like
bro just do nothing and say nothing
because the very least then we can try
to imagine what might you have been
doing but to be like I got on the phone
with some guys told her just let me know
what you need well thank god this is
worse than a mean tweet you know what I
mean this is this is a a tweet of like
I'm just going to placate you I'm gonna
say something so you so I can say I said
something and that's it you know I'd
rather have an outwardly mean tweet than
just something that placates people who
are really going through a hard time
let's be real but I didn't talk to
nobody he probably did nothing it's a
stock photo they probably took of him
weeks ago they probably have a whole
library of photos of him doing other
things you've got remember the picture
of him and it was It was supposed to be
at uh Camp David but then people noticed
the clock was not daylight savings time
and they're like wait a minute this had
to have been taken before March or like
before November or whatever proving that
either well maybe they don't update
their clocks or it was a stock photo of
the president this is probably a stock
photo they bring them in a room and they
say we're gonna get a bunch of different
photos if you're doing different things
to use in different moments I bet the
dude has no idea what's going on in Ohio
I bet he's just like I don't know they
told me got a plan to fly to Ukraine he
tweeted about it yesterday uh rail
companies have spent millions of dollars
to post Common Sense safety regulations
and it's worked more than a trained
derailment more than a toxic waste bill
it's years of opposition to safety
measures coming home to risk doesn't
match in Ohio it doesn't mention so
that's that's the same talking point as
Politico just put out right I mean it's
all Trump's fault basically right
because of of the of the regulations and
that seems to Obama did the same thing
with bush and I'm you know no fan of
bush but any it was seven years to do as
presidents and he was like oh well Bush
right it something went wrong it was
Bush's fault and that seems to be what
Biden is doing anytime he can just say
oh if it's wrong it's Trump's fault it
has nothing to do with what I've done
you just go back and look at previous
administration yeah I expect that out of
an Administration if they're going to
actually
do that in conjunction with taking
action to help relieve the situation on
the ground if there's going to be like
I'm not a fan of government anyways but
if there's going to be a government
that's that's if there's going to be an
EPA if there's going to be uh you know a
FEMA and stuff why aren't they helping
in the places that in the U.S that need
their help and the rail system is the
federal government's responsibility and
when you're talking about the the
chemicals and stuff this is the EPA this
is what they do yeah I was saying oh you
know go ahead I was told that he's been
offering Biden's been offering Federal
help to the governors but that they
haven't been requesting it he actually
says in his tweet as I said to your
Governors they'll have every resource
that they need indicating that they like
they're available for you Governors if
you need it but what is it is it the
federal government gives a state uh some
sort of FEMA relief then the state owes
the federal government something is it
like a Tit for Tat so the governor's
like I don't want to get involved with
Federal money I don't want you breathing
down my neck about that thing in the
future as a result I mean to some degree
but also like you know we pay taxes and
that's the point of them so that Federal
Emergency Management can come and assist
us when things like this happen but I
would think it would happen with no you
know no per uh Pro like what is it no
expectation of something in return well
I think the governor has to declare some
kind of state of emergency at some point
but other than that if you requested the
aid should be offered but I don't know
it it seems all very very strange that
that the federal government didn't jump
in at the beginning it didn't highlight
the issue at the beginning I mean it
seemed like when I first tweeted about
it which was early right I was getting
you know bought replies in my in my feed
saying oh you need to check your sources
on what actually is happening there and
this kind of a false Narrative of
everything is fine the people of pal
East Palestine are are just making a
mountain out of a mole hill everything's
okay and then it turns out absolutely
that's not the case it took JD Vance
going over there to do it to show people
but again we were fed a narrative or
when we were fed a narrative it turned
out to be completely false I posted I
retweeted the early image of like the
river the Ohio river and then all the
potentially affected States through the
water table and I just tweeted the image
I said I don't know there's nothing
verifying if this is real or not get
water filters get air filters don't wait
for official confirmation to take care
of yourself and I got a Twitter the next
day a warning said this is unverified
and someone's like Ian you got a word I
was like I'm fine with it I know I
didn't verify this is just take care of
yourself but then the next day they
removed the warning so like
that's interesting yeah yeah it was a
big thing where the New York Times
claimed the far-right conspiracy
theorists were saying the water table is
being threatened and I'm like the
governor of Ohio said that he said a
chemical plume is Flowing down river
towards West Virginia are we supposed to
assume that you can drink those
chemicals is that why it's safe on the
New York Times it's all about the power
of the first impression right it's it's
they put out these these narratives
hoping that okay the people that read
the New York Times are the people that
read The Washington Post they see that
at the beginning and they never look at
it again and anytime they see a story
about it after that they go oh that's
just crazy white right-wing conspiracy
theorists and so it's the power of that
first impression that they're trying to
Marshal there that's it's really
criminal I've got the the notice back on
I think the notice is on the thing I
retweeted it's not on my tweet so it
says the map is a high rear Basin does
not accurately represent areas of
potentially contaminated drinking water
multiple agencies and locales are
actively testing groundwater and
river-based drinking water and have
found no contamination have found no
contamination yet we've seen JD Vance's
video of contamination and a grocery
store is pulling water bottles off the
shelves you I wonder why I think this
notice can come down Twitter thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time